so you guys not only did you win best
actor you guys won best picture and
there was a moment on stage where let's
take a look at this here rami there's
rami he comes out from uh
and there's nicole kidman who you kind
of
like a high no you know call anyway now
what let's watch that
uh
i i had not seen that let's take a look
at that again in slow motion
and we could hear
[Applause]
i've known her for many years
yeah despite as it may seem from that
video yeah
uh so i thought i could easily go up and
say hi yeah moment like that it turned
out not to be the case very awkward i
have a feeling this is probably haunting
me
yeah this is going to be around for a
little while yeah yeah that's all right
you want to just give me a hint as to
what happened you dropped something on
the red carpet i did i did uh and
i never really had a
pocket checking policy prior to going
under the red carpet before but now um
now we've fully instated one um
you dropped a
a condom yeah on the red carpet which i
think kids was really it was really hard
for you to say no it wasn't actually
well i think gives you credit i mean you
know better to be safe than sorry right
it's a great message now to the many
messages in the film exactly right
you've got your own production company
what's next
what's next for you and that's a bad pun
by the way
your own production company uh what
what's next for you
oh man
[Music]
i broke my back what do you mean by that
your back is broken as soon as i felt
she probably dropped the camera i hit my
head boom i came back up quick because i
didn't want people to see i was hurt
there's only three people in the house i
jumped up and
so around three um around 3 30 in the
morning i went to the emergency room and
i saw around nine people in the
emergency room that fell off their
little boards too oh
in my 20s and i was just owning this
look i had a turtleneck i had mom jeans
on i was wearing a face
we've got the picture here there you are
it's a strong look it's it's something
and this was this was you being serious
yeah no oh yes i think i'm cool yeah
this is full on what is your cringiest
moment that you're not looking forward
to having to explain to your children in
the future
oh your cringiest moment from either
your life or from uh keeping up with the
kardashians i mean i think mine is
obvious right
and are you aware that this has now
become a sort of fancy dress outfit
like people do this they do this yeah as
a joke yeah that's seth rogen was on the
show yeah and he showed us his version
here's seth rogen as it
there's just a random man but very good
eye for detail
see
something weird happened at the golden
globe show and we have a clip of it i
wanted to play now damian chazelle got
the director and writer of your film i
think it was for best screenplay he won
yes and we'll show that clip because
we'll examine it
[Applause]
[Music]
this is damian schezel's first use
[Laughter]
now let's take a look at that again in
slow motion tell us what's what's
occurring here as damien goes to kiss
his girlfriend damian certainly wants to
hug not me
[Laughter]
you gotta choreograph that stuff you
know
for such a highly choreographed
film
it's kind of like a daily choreographer
in general no i'm general now yeah on
the left trick
[Applause]
that was awful it started to
it turned into a high five and it just
fell apart it was i never want to do
that again i never want to do that again
i never want to do that again i never
want to do that again
i never want to do that again
well we never did that again i never
want to do that again
look at my face i never want to do that
again
[Music]
who do you think was responsible for the
snl technical malfunction
oh me completely um what happened there
was i had a vocal problem i had two
nodes beating against each other and i
woke up and i had no voice and then i
should have said no i will not go on i
will not do this and would you do the
show again if they asked i did do it
again which nobody talks about they're
like oh that bad happens
oh you went back on
okay someone looks good okay he looks
like he's hiding a frog in his mouth and
it's uncomfortably hopping around in
there but he can't open his mouth
you know what's funny about that one is
i've posted that picture myself
to show people that i thought it was
really funny and then weeks go by and
i'd look at myself in the mirror and be
like maybe i do look like i have a plug
in my mouth i went into a little spiral
i don't know if i can do red carpets
anymore yeah it's kind of scary i'm
gonna kill you
i don't i think that's a look of love
rather than anger to be honest i think
there's there's definitely sort of a
glint of desire in his eyes rather than
death wish so i think that's an
inaccurate
meme
yeah um
but have you do you do you know but do
you kind of
actively avoid them because some of them
i mean thinking about the frog one is
kind of weirder than others uh
i try to not what i've tried to stop
doing is after red carpets and stuff
stop looking at the pictures from the
night before because i end up just
picking everything apart
um
and but no i'm very lucky i have really
lovely fans they're very kind uh they're
really supportive and uh
wherever there's a negative comment i
love just watching my fans rip them
apart that's why it's so fun so uh so no
i i try to avoid it as much as i can but
sometimes it's impossible congrats to
shape of water
maybe i should date a fish hey jimmy
kimmel what's in your wallet wait
where's my wallet can't wait to work
with lena dunham wait did i sign a
nudity waiver
[Music]
growing up your mom your parents called
you dewey yes and and
you had a lot of nicknames there's a lot
of nicknames
[Laughter]
what was behind that dewey yes yeah i
saw that as dew drops and then oh god
when he was when he was a pebble
he was uh do drops and then from there
it was doo doo and then
[Applause]
so what did your kids call you
uh i make them call me sir
i saw this uh footage someplace a year
someplace and there's a guy and you beat
up a guy that was trying to hug you i
didn't beat up a guy
hoofed him
no no
what was the guy where were you first i
was in in moscow and we're doing the
what was the guy doing
we're doing an interview right right
yeah and he says man you know like uh
you know he's a reporter and he says i'm
your biggest fan can you you know can i
have a hug please so i go to give this
joke a hug and
he like tries to lean in to like kiss me
you know and now that's first of all
how much it's just awkward dave
[Applause]
i i can see where it would be yeah but
what what kind of a journalist oh here's
my thing yeah you know i'm dan rather
i'm going to see if i can't kiss people
yeah you know but what what is that i
don't know that's what they were saying
they were like oh no we're sorry you
know uh it's just his shtick you know
and i said well that's why his ass got
stuck yeah no
it's really a surprise for somebody
guthrie ladies and gentlemen
[Laughter]
i think we should uh roll a certain clip
get off the furniture
what is going on
[Music]
[Applause]
my goodness that happened